breaking now a tentative agreement
between ccsd and the teachers union to
settle the contract for thousands of
local educators the two groups just made
the announcement a short time ago good
afternoon thanks so much for joining us
at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas we want to get right
out to joe mueller joe good afternoon
what can you tell us
well christian the school district and
the union say that these contract
agreements will address a few major
problems including the concerns that
many have been having about the backlog
of health insurance claims now there was
two agreements that were discussed here
at the ccsd headquarters today one is
with the teachers union and the other is
with the school administrators and
association of professional technical
employees as for the teachers union
there will be a 3 percent increase in
salary for licensed employees and step
increases after that through june of
2023 officials also say they will be
paying the backlog of insurance claims
that many teachers are dealing with
the agreement is going to provide the
type of
guard rails as well as revenue to
address a backlog of claims that have to
be settled upon as well as moving
forward making sure that each and every
educator and their families have access
to a constitution continuity of care
back out here live both of these
contracts address pay benefits and
development opportunities superintendent
jesus jarrah says these contracts also
start to address the recruitment
entertainment issue that is going on
here in the district he says that's an
issue that many school districts are
dealing with across the country right
now
next what happens with both of these
agreements is that the board will have
to approve the tentative agreements we
also have much more on both of these
agreements on our website that is
8newsnow.com reporting live at the ccsd
headquarters joe mohler live local now